- Happy Valentine's day,
once again, everybody
but was Valentine's day a big
deal for y'all growing up?
And is it a big deal for y'all like now?
- I mean, no, first of all,
when I was growing up, I
liked the action of you know,
when you're a little
girl in elementary school
and you had to hand out all those cards,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- to different boys.
That was like when I got
the party started, you know?
- I, I never got that card.
(laughter)
- When I was a girl, like
third or fourth grade,
I loved that, you get all the Valentines
and you give all the Valentines, you know?
And then as I grew up,
I was like, this is such
a stupid holiday, you know,
forcing people to be romantic on days,
you know, it's just too manufactured.
- Yeah, it's pressure.
- So I appreciate people who
are single on this holiday.
Like please, have as much fun as possible
because it's just such a silly,
I mean obviously I'm in love with you
and I'm happy to, but don't-
- Hey man, it shows.
(laughter)
You're really selling it, honey!
- But don't go overboard.
- Gotta get rid of these.
(laughter)
- We hate flowers and cars.
- I don't know what I was thinking,
I bought her flowers
- I don't like any organized thing
where people say on this
day, you must do this.
- It's pressure.
I don't like it, I love giving gifts.
It stresses me out so much
to have to have a planned thing.
I don't know why
but do you get each other
gifts or y'all not doing that?
Cause here's my thing.
At some point, you can buy your own,
I'm always like, I can buy my own stuff.
I don't need you to buy me stuff.
So I'd rather have
something, I don't know.
I like something made or a
card or something like that.
- Yeah, I always appreciate
a card with writing.
- [Kelly] Like meaningful.
- Yeah. Much more than any gift.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- Cause you could buy your own stuff.
- Exactly.
And I do.
- Me too!
(laughter)
- Yeah, and we do, and we should.
And also, I think another point
about 'single-dom' and
the people, you know
the woman who was talking earlier
in your audience about
being single, like please
I can't tell single women enough
to enjoy your 'single-dom'.
You are not going to be single for long.
Nobody's ever single forever, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So enjoy and embrace it and
use it as that time to prepare
for the guy or the girl that's coming.
(audience cheers)